- Welcome back, y'all.
During the holidays,
we had Danny DeVito here
promoting his animated movie "Migration."
I love him so much.
And if you haven't seen it yet,
it is a great watch for the whole family.
It's so good.
The thing is, though,
that Danny and I had a lot to talk about;
we're both talkers,
so much, there was an
overflow of great content.
You're welcome, America, in advance.
Luckily, we have a chance to
share it right now with you.
Here is our Kelly Extra with Danny DeVito,
starting with maybe the
craziest audition story
I've ever heard.
So I heard also, whenever
you used to audition,
that you used to do crazy
things at your auditions.
- [Danny] Yeah.
- Well, like, what does that mean?
- Well, the thing about an audition
is you want to make an
impression, so yeah-
- Stand out.
- Yeah, you want to really stand out.
- Yeah.
- And a couple of 'em, I,
one was,
my first one was I was
auditioning for a play
that was at the public theater.
And then, you know,
you just go to all these auditions
when you're an actor.
Everybody who tries to
do this knows the drill.
And you go and you wind up
meeting the casting directors
and they know you after a while
if they bring you in for many things.
And some, you know,
a lot, most of 'em, you don't get,
you don't get.
So, but you wanna make an impression.
And there was this one director
who was doing a play,
he was doing "Threepenny Opera," okay?
And it's,
and I said, "Look, it's a small part.
It's one monologue."
It's like,
you know,
"Open the door."
When you open the door -
'cause I knew the casting woman -
I said, "Stand back.
Just stand back."
And she said, "Oh, Danny,"
you know, like, "What are you gonna do?"
(people laughing) I said,
"Don't worry about it.
Doesn't-"
You know,
so she did it,
and I laid down and I rolled in.
(people laughing)
Right?
And I was doing my monologue.
I rolled-
- While you're rolling?
- Yeah.
I started it.
By the time I got to the
middle of the audition -
it was a little speech -
I was actually on my back,
looking up at the director.
(people laughing)
And he's looking down at me like,
"This guy is (bleep)."
Yeah.
- Insane.
- No, not funny.
I was gonna say something else.
- You were gonna say-
- No, I was gonna say
something else with an F.
- Yeah.
- He's insane.
- And,
and, you know,
and I finished and I just kind of,
and everybody was like,
you could hear a pin drop.
And the guy went like this:
"Thank you very much."
(everyone laughing)
I didn't get the part.
(people clapping)
- You waited by the phone.
Way to go.
(Kelly clapping)
I hear you also have a unique warmup
that you do, like, in theater?
- Yeah.
- Like, what do you do?
- I have a trampoline.
I have a great-
- Like the mini trampoline?
- Yeah, it's like about this size.
- Yeah. No, I have one.
- Right?
A little bit lower than this.
- Yeah.
- And I put it
in my dressing room.
And before you go,
you know, the whole idea
is you gotta get, you know, juiced up.
You saw the show.
- Yeah.
- Pretty high energy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so
I need that, you know?
I need to get in there and-
- Yeah.
- So, anyway,
I get in there before,
you know, I come early,
get ready.
I get disheveled.
My hair is way, way wilder
than this in the show.
(people laughing)
- Yeah.
- And...
(Kelly laughing)
- I love you so much.
- [Danny] She can testify
to that. (Kelly clapping)
And, you know,
and I get ready to go,
because we go right from the jump.
As soon as that curtain opens,
you know, the audience
is ready, in for a ride.
You gotta hang on.
So we go.
And so I need to get my stuff going,
you know, my blood
- Yeah.
- and all my lymph glands,
everything shaking.
- You need to get pumped.
This is your pump.
- So I pump on this thing.
- Yeah.
- I go up and down. Yeah,
I get ready on that. Yeah.
- I cannot skip or jump on a
trampoline without smiling.
- Well, it's a great thing.
- I know. It makes me happy.
- The thing I have to do, though,
is I really do have to hold on.
(people laughing)
- Oh.
- I have to hold on.
I'll hold onto the wall
or I'll hold onto, like,
there's, like, a coat hook
that's nearby
that I dread winding up on.
(people laughing)
But I hold onto it.
- I'm the,
I'm, like, not,
I'm a bad mom.
I will get on with my daughter
and be like, "Let's play Crack the Egg."
And I'm trying to pop her up.
(people laughing)
- Oh, yeah?
- And she's like, "Mom,
don't jump with me.
Don't jump."
I'm like, I'm trying to just make her fly.
Like, yeah.
I'm opposite.
I've also been highly
injured on one before.
I, like, right before -
you can edit this out -
but right before was school picture day.
The next day.
This was literally what happened.
I was on my friend Lauren's trampoline
and I was trying to see
how high I could get,
and I was, like,
all of a sudden I was up there
and I was like, "Oh my god,
I'm as tall as this tree."
And I was coming down.
I was like, "I am not
over the trampoline."
(people laughing)
And I racked myself
and then fell on the ground
and face-hit a fire ant pile.
(audience reacting) Have
you ever had fire ant bites?
Well, it looks like acne.
And it literally was like
I had fire ant bites
that looked like pimples.
(audience reacting)
I was really cool in school.
(people laughing)
- That is-
- I was hit on an
extraordinary amount of times.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Alright, y'all.
Remember to catch Danny in
"Migration." We love you.